naughty dog might not make another last
of his game according to director Neil
druckman in an interview with BuzzFeed
druckmann stated that there's no
pressure from Sony the Studio's owner to
produce more last of his games despite
the franchise's massive success
especially in the wake of its new
equally successful TV show in the
interview druckman points to the
Studio's previous Mega hit franchise
Uncharted as an example of walking away
from a project when it feels like it's
time to move on quote for us Uncharted
was insanely successful Uncharted 4 was
one of our best selling games and we
were able to put our final brush stroke
on that story and say that we're done
we're moving on drockman continues quote
if we can't come up with something for a
Last of Us Part 3 we have a very strong
ending with parts two and that will be
the end naunty dog does have a
multiplayer last of his game in the
works with more to be revealed on that
this year which drockman describes in
the interview as the next chapter of the
franchise in a previous interview
druckman confirmed the game would have a
new cast of characters and would tell a
story while it would seem
incomprehensible that naughty dog would
walk away from The Last of Us at the
height of its popularity druckman does
make a good point they walked away from
Uncharted after putting out its most
popular installment and if Sony had
forced naughty dog to just keep making
Uncharted games because they were huge
hits we never would have got the last of
us maybe druckmann and the team have a
passion project they're ready to tackle
Tango Gameworks certainly did and from
the buzz online Xbox and Bethesda have a
hit new game that no one knew about
until just yesterday a surprise
announcement during Xbox's developer
direct video the developers Behind The
Evil Within and ghostwire Tokyo revealed
a very different kind of game and you
can play it right now Hi-Fi Rush is a
colorful full action rhythm game
featuring an animation style similar to
into the spite of us it features the
character chai and his robot cat
companion 808 as he takes on the
mechanical minions of a vandelay
Technologies the game requires the
player to time their movements and
attacks to the beat of the music with
Advanced Combos and skills to learn I've
played a couple of hours and can't wait
to dive into more the title is available
via game pass on Xbox and PC but can be
purchased on both for thirty dollars if
you don't have a subscription if you do
have Game Pass Xbox pulled out all the
stops to turn around its January which
was initially looking very light on top
of Hi-Fi rush and upres golden eye which
is being added on Friday subscribers
will also be able to pick up Age of
Empire's 2 Definitive Edition and new
indie game inkle naughty on January 31st
and then at the start of February
darkest dungeon grid Legends and Hot
Wheels Unleashed game of the Year
Edition will kick off the next month for
the service from a kickoff to a kick
flip skate developers address the recent
rumors around loot boxes in the series
upcoming reboot a report earlier this
week from Insider gaming shed that
current playtesters say the game
features the ability to pay for an
in-game currency that lets you purchase
loot boxes following these rumors the
official skate account on Twitter put
out a reminder about the game saying
it's quote not pay to win no map areas
locked behind paywall no paid loot boxes
and no paid gameplay advantages from
what it sounds like there will be loot
boxes that you can pay for but that the
Cosmetics inside them will all be
obtainable via loot boxes that you can
gain via gameplay which if you're going
to do loot boxes is the way to do them
as long as the time investment asked out
of the player to put in Via gameplay to
do so is reasonable which time will tell
if that's the case would you be upset if
we never got a Last of Us Part 3 are you
gonna be playing Hi-Fi rush or GoldenEye
this weekend let us know in the comments
and we'll see you here for more Gamespot
news